like I was telling you earlier I'm doing
a project called 30 people one question
but I thought I switch it up today and
just go out and film things and people
that I find beautiful okay question I
thought I just go out and some people
and things that I think are thank you
well what's the question sorry
[Music]
people on things that I think are
beautiful okay
oh well that's sleep like that oh thank
you that's my question is now you choose
the wrong person you know I get really
shy thank you oh you're beautiful thank
you
how does it feel to be beautiful great I
guess how does it feel to be beautiful
[Music]
like copy on guard um well thank you
no I guess like compliments can you feel
a little awkward at times but it's a
nice gesture I guess I don't know how it
feels I guess feels good to like have
someone say that
kind of makes your day oh that's really
nice it takes one to know one
how does it feel to be beautiful oh
thank you very much and wonderful if
something's gonna tell me I'm beautiful
that's great Wow well I'm impressed yes
I made the cut take photos and videos of
things I find beautiful okay alright umm
people and things that I find beautiful
okay
that I think are beautiful okay so
that's that's it people and things that
I think are beautiful
[Music]
how does it feel to be beautiful yeah I
don't know I don't really think of
myself as beautiful most of the time but
it's nice to hear I guess thank you how
does it feel to be beautiful just like
you can get away with anything thank you
that's it thank you okay I'm supposed to
react to that today's a little bit
different I thought I'd go out and just
film people on things that I think are
beautiful okay and film people on things
that I think are beautiful okay that's
pretty much it cool like that let's go
to do oh thank you that's so nice thank
you you're welcome what a good project
is there question still I do have the
question is all time what do you think
is the most beautiful thing about you
oh wow um I think the most beautiful
thing about me is
[Music]
guys my name is aya and I'm the owner of
this channel I'm also the person behind
the camera and I thought I'd take a
minute to thank all the subscribers I
gained so far and maybe ask new years to
hit the subscribe button if you liked
this episode or if you're a fan of my
channel in general the new lon
thank you